the voyage of the Parker Solar Probe is
about to begin its seven-year mission to
boldly go where no craft has gone before
to touch the Sun to seek out answers to
questions like why is the Sun's corona
so dang hot smaller and speedier than
starships past NASA's Parker Solar Probe
is set to blast off from Cape Canaveral
and aboard a delta 4 heavy rocket the
largest NASA's Arsenal after clearing
Earth's atmosphere Parker will shed its
rocket and get one last boost then
spring-loaded gadgets that were stowed
for launch emerge
solar panels pop out and start charging
the cooling system revs up and antennas
and other instruments stretch out into
space six weeks after launch parker
reaches venus it'll use Venus's gravity
to slingshot itself toward the Sun
another six weeks later Parker becomes
the first spacecraft to enter the sun's
outer atmosphere or Corona the corona is
actually hotter than the surface of the
Sun but a pancake shaped heat shield
keeps all of Parker's gadgets a little
above room temperature most of the
spacecraft's solar panels also tucked
behind the carbon composite shield to
avoid melting traveling at high speeds
will prevent Parker from getting pulled
into the Sun
as the probe surfs the sun's atmosphere
it will gather important intel on solar
radiation electric fields magnetic
fields and particles the data could help
explain what heats up the corona and how
solar wind escapes the Sun and
accelerates through the solar system
[Music]
then Parker swoops back out to cold dark
space and transmits its data back to
earth it'll do the same thing 23 more
times sweeping by the Sun every 88 days
Venus will give the probe six more
slingshot assists and each time it will
inch closer to the sun's surface while
Parker is close to the Sun it won't be
able to radio home so the probe will
have to fly solo tiny solar sensors tell
the craft shimmy left or right when
they're exposed to too much Sun parts of
Parker will get hit with 475 times the
solar radiation that the spacecraft
experienced in orbit around Earth the
probes final three orbits will take it
within six point three million
kilometers of the sun's surface that's
seven times closer than the current
record-holder helios - back in 1976
on its final orbit Parker will also come
in fast and furious at a top speed of
690 thousand kilometers per hour or 190
kilometers per second it'll be the
fastest human-made object in the solar
system at that speed he could travel
from New York to Tokyo in under a minute
so top that Vin Diesel the mission is
set for seven years but it could go
longer whenever Parker meets its end
it'll go out in a blaze of glory once
the probe runs out of fuel most of it
will burn up in the very star it was
said to study but not the heat shield
that giant carbon disc will continue to
orbit the Sun for billions of years
[Music]
[Music]